We usually think of cities as the
opposite of nature.
But what if we started looking at them as nature of a different kind?
Plants and animals already use our
buildings and bridges as habitat,
and our parks and gardens attract birds,
reptiles and insects.
Sometimes these are the species that used to live here long before we arrived.
Often, they're species that we've brought from somewhere else.
And some of them are species that are endangered in their original habitats.
Red-crowned parrots were brought to
California from Mexico by the tens of
thousands for the pet trade in the 1960s
and 70s.
They're now endangered in their home range,
but enough of them escaped that
several thousand of them now thrive in
eastern Los Angeles. It doesn't mean they're a
native species but it does mean that
they're now a permanent part of our
urban landscapes.
That just happened by luck, but the Red-crowned parrots could also offer an
inspiring model for opening up our city
to other endangered species.
Those that used to live here, but also species from
other places
that might find a home in Los Angeles.
Spotted turtles, which are
endangered on the East Coast, might find
an ecological niche here... and so could
endangered geckos.
In the future,
perhaps our cities could serve as urban arks
that offer sanctuary to humans and
non-humans, natives and non-natives alike.